Kernfusion ist das thema wenn es
Um die energieerzeugung der zukunft geht sie funktioniert nach dem großen vorbild der sonne
An kampflos ins kraftwerk würde eine unmenge an der energieerzeugung und konnte somit vielleicht schon bald die lösung aller energieprobleme
auf unserer erde seien aber noch
funktioniert es nicht aber wie nah sind wir dran wird einer der prototypen vielleicht schon bald strom erzeugen
Die fünf projekte die am dichtesten dran sind jetzt mal klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen übrigens von der re publica in berlin
Ihr habt euch dieses thema wie whatsapp gewünscht wird damit dabei sein könnt und hiermit bestimmt was läuft
Das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos das geht übrigens auch mit anderen messen
Ihr wisst alle weiter kernfusionstechnik gibt es noch viele offene fragen die es zu beantworten gilt doch
Am ende winkt im besten fall tatsächlich eine kernfusion die
umweltverträglich sauberen strom produzieren und damit den immer weiter steigenden
energiebedarf der erde denken könnten doch vorher sind noch folgende probleme anzugehen wie
Beispielsweise kann man es schaffen mehr energie aus dem fusionsprozess herauszuholen als man ihn einspringen das ist das hauptproblem
aus wirtschaftlicher sicht dazu kommen die beiden folgenden herausforderungen
Wie und wann wird es forschungsteams gelingen in einem fusionskraftwerk einen plasma strom dauerhaft
Am brennen zu halten und welches material lässt sich finden
das den krassen belastungen an der innenwand des plasma gefäßes stellen ich stelle euch jetzt
fünf projekte vor die in meinen augen aus verschiedenen gründen
Erfolg versprechen scheinen diese probleme in angriff zu nehmen und zu lösen oder auch eine alternative lösung
Ja, zu haben auf der 5 general fusion das millionengrab heiße plasma wird hier in einer drei meter großen
Stahlkugel erzeugt enthalten ist eine mischung aus flüssigen lithium und blei von oben und unten
Werden ringe aus wasserstoff plasma geschaffen von außen schießen jetzt mechanisch folge auf dieses gemisch
geschwindigkeit 100 meter pro sekunde dabei wird das plasma so stark verdichtet dass eine fusionsreaktion zündet hoch energetische neutronen
In die blei lithium schmelze und heißt sie auf die wiederum gibt der energie in einem wärmetauscher ab es wird energie
Erzeugt zurzeit arbeitet die firma an einem reaktor der die größe von 70 eines späteren kommerziellen
reaktors haben soll schon in wenigen jahren den general fusion einen
Marktreifen reaktor anbieten können allerdings scheinen hier die ziele noch ein wenig um konkret
Zu sein es kann also noch dauern auf der vier talker markus reaktor sc 40 den hat man ja vor kurzem
Vorgestellt an der weiterentwicklung der fusionsenergie ist auch. Eben das britische unternehmen talker mark energy
Beteiligt der aktion namens ackermann sc 40 ist noch jung er wurde erst 2017 in betrieb genommen und das erste plasma
Konnte erzeugt werden ihre reaktoren also von
Soccer marques de 40 dieser reaktor funktioniert anders als beispielsweise der stellarator aus greifswald
Denn hier wird das magnetfeld zum teil von einem
Im plasma fließenden strom erzeugt das konzept beim töpfermarkt basiert also auf dem magnetischen einschluss
Ein plasma aus wasserstoff isotopen wird so auf etwa 100 bis 150
millionen grad erhitzt laut der offiziellen webseite von docker mark energy besteht die erste phase des prozesses darin platz mit temperaturen von
15 millionen grad celsius zu erreichen also so heißt wie das zentrum der sonne noch in diesem jahr den zuckermarkt energy dann 100 millionen grad
erreichen dann erst dann würden die geladenen thorium tritium partikel die sich normalerweise
Absturz hinter schmelzen ziel des unternehmens ist es. Im jahr 2025 mit dem sc 40 erst sehr
elektrizitätserzeugung
2025 und bis 2030 soll dann auch kommerziell nutzbare fusionsenergie
Hergestellt werden das ist also eine echte perspektive aber ist der e technologies mit seinem test reaktor normen
Näher dran da auf der drei das startup unternehmen mit einem besonderen plan das dritte projekt hier tanzt etwas
Aus der reihe das ist nicht staatlich sondern an us start up namens der
technologies unter den unterstützern und investoren sind einige wirklich namhafte leute aus der wirtschaft
Und technologie szene zu leben hat das startup mit google zusammen gearbeitet
Um algorithmen für seine experimente zu produzieren damit soll eine bessere
stabilisierung und kontrolle, des wirklich empfindlichen plasmas gewährleistet werden zudem nutzt das start-up supercomputer
Des us energieministeriums, um seine datenverarbeitung
Prozesses mitte 2017 konnte in dem 20 meter langen und fünf meter und es wirkt enormen einfluss war es
fünf millisekunden stabil gehalten werden für die erzeugung von diskussions strom ist das natürlich viel zu kurz aber und plasma parameter zu
analysieren und zu optimieren sei dies völlig
Ausreichend so die verantwortlichen das besondere an diesem ansatz ist die ist bei der techno richtigen übrigens die verwendung des
Isotopen vor elf anstatt wie üblich die beiden schweren wasserstoff über truppe dort terium und tritium der prozess läuft wie folgt
gebündelte strahlen dass protonen diene zur erzeugung eines möglichen dichten und
Langlebigen plasmas das board wird getrennt in die ziele die protonen werden mit 900.000 kilometern pro stunde ins zentrum
Des reaktors geschossen und durch ihre koalition entsteht eine unfassbare hitze sie ist für die kernfusion mit dem bohr
Notwendig einzigartig ist dass sich das heiße plasma durch ein selbst erzeugt das magnetfeld stabilisiert dadurch ist ein
extern aufgebaut das magnetfeld das bei
Etwa notwendig ist um die geladenen teilchen sicher einzuschließen
Überflüssig das ist ein komplett anderes prinzip als in den restlichen
forschungsreaktor dort wird ein plasma in einem ring erzeugt bei treffer werden zwei klassen
An zwei enden einer röhre erzeugt und dann?
aufeinander geschossen jetzt hier ist das plasma dann so heißt dass die fusion in gang kommen
bei diesem verfahren entsteht das heiße plasma ja wohl deutlich und aufwendiger denn mit der
investition von lediglich einer halben milliarden dollar will die firma schon bis spätestens 2030 aber eher 2027
Einen funktionierenden prototypen gebaut haben damit liegen sie ziemlich gut im rennen auf der zweites projekt das kernfusionsprojekt
Wendelstein 7-x kreis falls werden darüber berichtet, im vergangenen herbst sind die experimente nach großen umbauarbeiten am kernfusion
experimentellen stand 7 xp grad heißt wieder losgegangen fusions relevante plasmen mit einer heizleistung von acht megawatt strom erzeugt werden
Tatsächlich doppelt so viel wie bisher das plasma wird dabei unvorstellbare 70 millionen grad heiß und soll nach den vorstellungen des greifswalder
forschungsteams zehn sekunden lang stabil bleiben das ist gar nicht so unrealistisch denn experten und expertinnen
Halten die kernfusion anlage für eine der modernsten forschungsanlagen überhaupt das erste plasma wurde ende
2015 erzeugt danach folgten rund 1000 experimente
dabei wurden tatsächlich in elektronen temperaturen von bis zu 100 millionen grad celsius und ionen temperaturen von bis zu 20 millionen grad celsius
Erreichen mit neuen messinstrumenten einer leistungsfähigeren heizung und einem hitzeschild will das greifswalder
forschungsteam leistung die leistung der mikrowellen heizung auf 80 5 megawatt verdoppeln und eine höhere dichte und temperatur des plasmas entziehen
Und das in dauerbetrieb geplant sind unter anderem experimente zur stabilität, des plasmas zum einsturz
des plasmas in den magnet ring und auch zur heizung nach diesem ersten meilenstein sind dann weitere umbauten geplant um in etwa drei jahren
plasmen für eine dauer von einer halben stunde
aufzubauen das wäre wirklich ein riesiger schritt dafür soll die heizung leistung langfristig um weitere 2 megawatt erhöht werden unter anderem durch
kohlenstofffaserverstärkte kohlenstoff elemente die bislang von
kacheln
Sollen damit ersetzt werden die ergebnisse von forschungsteams weltweit dann bei ihren plänen weiter
helfen langfristig ein kraftwerk zu entwickeln indem letztendlich elektrischer strom gewonnen wird denn das ist das ziel von wendelstein 7-x
Sollen alle vorarbeiten für den bau eines kraftwerks dieses stellarator typs geleistet werden und es scheint als läuft hier wirklich alles nach plan
das klingt wirklich
Vielversprechend und auf der 1 der größte fusionsreaktor der welt bei sant pol de toros
Im süden von frankreich wird derzeit der größte fusionsreaktor der welt gebaut sein name ist das steht für international
Thermonukleare experimente reaktor die lateinische bedeutung von iter ist weg und vielleicht ist dieser weg tatsächlich der richtige
Um erstmalig in einem fusionsprozess energie zu gewinnen an diesem projekt wird deutlich dass, man weltweit eingesehen hat dass
Nationale alleingänge keinen sinn machen an den fusionsreaktor in frankreich arbeitet die halbe. Welt zusammen die
europäischen staaten zusammen mit russland usa indien japan südkorea und china die kosten werden wohl bei rund
15 milliarden euro liegen wobei die hälfte davon aus der eu kommt technisch gesehen basiert
Auf dem töpfermarkt prinzip doch bei diesem konzept des magnetischen einschluss es soll ein reifen förmiger
Magnetfeld käfig das plasma deutlich länger zusammen denn an dieser sogenannten energie ein schuss zeit hat ist bislang noch
Etat übertrifft alle bisherigen projekte durch sein verhältnis von volumen zur oberfläche sein plasma volumen beträgt achtung
Unglaubliche 8 140 kubikmeter und dass es eben notwendig. Um die verlust prozesse möglichst klein zu halten
Im jahr 2025 soll dann das erste plasma gezündet werden nach weiteren
Installationen ist das eigentlich der ziel für 2035 an gewalt der betrieb mit deuterium und tritium sie zu einem neukunden an einem
helium kern fusionieren und in der letzten stufe soll etwa krasse
500 megawatt fusions leistung erzeugen also das ist wirklich der erste reaktor wo man ganz konkret der weiß der wird wenn
Nicht irgendwas richtig schief geht der wird wirklich funktionieren aber die anfangs von
angesprochen ist ja nicht nur der fusions leistungswert ansicht von bedeutung sondern vor allem auch das verhältnis
der fusions zeitung zur extern heizleistung der kuh wert ein verstärkung faktor der bisherige rekord liegt ja bei q
0,7 liter soll den der zehn erreichen womit das erste mal ein wert größer als 1 realisiert wurde und eben energie
Gewonnen werden können ja wenn er als erstes neues zum thema kernfusion und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
Hierbei war z wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch auch mit anderen messen jamie telegramm instagram oder den facebook messenger
verknüpfen an der fahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vom kick zum mitmachen und mitbestimmen
Was hierbei geht es um passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines kind
Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke also wir bringen genau vergessen hier geht es weiter
Also hiermit die lüge der energiewende ansonsten ist dann
bleibt